hello everyone and it's truly an honor
to have you all here I'm here to talk
about Orchestra a project we built in
amp x8 the largest student hackathon in
the USA and who actually won the first
prize but before I start talking about
the project let me introduce you to the
team who actually built this first we
have Aditya the violin virtuoso and
music theory expert who likes to use
artificial intelligence augmented
reality to deliver education to the
world's most underserved populations
then we have Ezra we have Ezra our
Harbor and digital signal processing
whiz who's very interested in delivering
emerging technologies just several
different populations in the world then
we have sarthak our very own creative
hacker who built oregon the first
augmented reality web browser it Finders
me I'm deep learning nerd Prime the deep
learning nerd of the project I like to
integrate artificial intelligence into
hospitals should make better simpler
diagnostics of heart diseases now enough
about us and let's talk more about this
project so there's this concept that we
really like to emphasize in here which
is the notion of computational
collaboration the notion their
artificial intelligence systems when
they're in symbiosis with humans can
create truly beautiful products whose
value is far greater than the sum of all
individual components with that concept
in mind we created orchestra orchestra
is a module they can compose create and
even improvised music now as a part of
this pipeline there are two modules the
first one is improvisational module
which an improvised music on the fly and
the second one is a neuro module which
can compose tracks now sarthak here is
an explain much more how we can
improvise music
so before I start talking about the
improvisational module I'd like to spend
some time delving into what exactly was
our inspiration for the project what
exact why did we decide to do something
this crazy so 10 years ago I used to
play the piano curr and I was I was a
little budding virtuoso as so as you can
tell I like composing melodies I'd like
getting them done but when I would try
and play this with other people I was
terrible I had no sense of tempo and I
could just not play with other people
and that actually demotivated me and
cause me to quit thing a few years later
but even if you've been playing the an
instrument for the past nine years like
a death you you still have difficulty in
finding other people to play with and
it's always a matter of coordinating
with other people or finding the people
with the right compliment people that
you can just jump it and have fun with
to address this need we created
Orchestra am and to fundamentally
capture the essence of this we created
the improvisational module first now the
improvisational module is pretty simple
and it consists of three different steps
the first step is a system to transfer
high-quality continuous audio data from
our violin or to a laptop to do
processing now this is where we had to
get creative because it turns out it's
actually really difficult to get audio
data that doesn't degrade over time so
we try this with Arduino and we tried
this with the studio quality microphones
and our audio is just degrading and we
couldn't do any good processing with it
so we literally hacked the most
unexpected thing which was apples your
pods so you know the microphone on your
pots it turns out that by duct-taping is
literally duct taping it underneath the
bridge of the violin and then connecting
the earpods to the headphone jack
your laptop you can actually get live
continuous high quality audio data that
can then be used and processed and
manipulated word this was this is quite
cool we weren't expecting this the next
part of the pipeline involves a way to
convert the analog data the analog data
from the microphone to a digital data a
convert the digital audio data the
continuous audio data into smaller
samples each was just one or two notes
and finally applying fast Fourier
transforms on the on the notes to
convert it from audio frequencies into
the corresponding textual
representations of notes now the most
challenging part of this was to find the
right sampling frequencies because when
you're playing a violin you one of the
common techniques is to actually very
the tempo to make it sound more
interesting and we accomplished this by
basically comparing the average
distances between amplitudes of
different notes and by averaging these
distances we match to calculate a rough
approximation for what the something
great should be finally having converted
these audio samples into a continuous
stream of text characters we then mapped
these text characters into an
accompanying output sequence of tax
characters that we know sound good
because of music theory we accomplish
this through the help of an AI expert
system which you can just think of as
consisting of a many different rules and
boolean expressions heuristics things
like chord progressions musical scales
harmonies with this knowledge given a
sequence of input notes you can make
good predictions for what the output
should be like like in jars on the
result and wolfram turns out to be
really good at this particular part of
the process because of the new features
introduced in version 11 visualizing the
output and doing the signal processing
all that is a breeze and you can really
visualize you can visualize the output
of this as MIDI files and these MIDI
files can be played back as many
different instruments
um which we will show in the demo from M
Hawks part sorry for the bad quality we
required is in stage but here it is some
things I much better show in San right
so out of your own life
[Music]
so basically what's happening there is
you see our implementation phase so this
is the first phase of a two stage
pipeline so here in real time we
generate music the bunk mate would add a
test playing right now so based on music
theory based on what notes coed what
notes what power to look for this is
what we're doing
[Music]
this is happening in real time now one
of the limitations of this approach was
because of the 36-hour deadline our
accompaniment was monophonic this meant
that you could not have multiple nodes
thing at the same time or you could not
have rich of depth into this this is
something that we address with the help
of a neural network which Ralph will
talk about in more detail definitely so
let's talk about a new module I was very
interested in how we could improvise
music right in a spot there's something
that really fascinated me about our fish
intelligence can you make your networks
compose and create music so that's we
try to accomplish in your module so
first we got recurring your networks and
train them on a hundred and fifty years
worth of music how do we actually in put
it as music shin in your network you
mask sorry back yes we use a format
called MIDI which literally contains
notes for how long they're being played
their volumes and their amplitudes and
if this computers collects you read
those kinds of notes and then understand
how they sound like so we basically
convert this into text and pass it in to
the car RNN a recurring your network
recurring your network module call me
Andrew Carpathia at Stanford so Star
Trek you finna go for next one so this
is your architecture so it basically
uses a mechanism called back propagation
over time in order to understand how
data is structured over a temporal
dimension so what in other words let's
say you have sweet child of mine by Guns
and Roses it was a really good guitar
solo in the middle followed up by a very
upbeat chorus right that's the way the
music is structured so by understanding
the way music structured over time you
can kind of deduct how notes would fit
in together in a somewhat evonik way so
I'm just getting through more detail the
way to network strain is by literally
putting some character at a time step
and having a network predict what's
going to be the next input so same so a
given T predict t plus 1 you train over
the huge corpus of data that we had on
Beethoven symphonies Bach violin concert
owes everything if they imagine about
classical music and we did it but do it
turns out that in the same way that
humans have different musical
capabilities artificial intelligences
also compose different quality of music
the painting architecture and a waiter
trained and the car and n didn't do
really really well in this domain
sometimes they would cram literally a
hundred notes in 10 seconds just to stay
quiet for 30 seconds so even a guy who
knows anything nothing about music could
play you know almost the same as n so
then we contacted this guy call
hexahedron he has a very good block on
your networks for music and we thought
can we actually learn some music music
theory structure in order to make museum
or more euphonic in order to make music
sound better so that's what we did so
enter the biaxial recurrent neural
network in the same way that you can
learn structure over time using the
character return your network this is
your network creates a whole new no
taxes in which you can encode how
different notes and different chords
relate to each other so we had to make
some changes the input pipeline as well
encoding information about the previous
states next States which chords are
played if a note was being held or only
strummed but if you guys are real
interested in details you guys can just
record github page like they're all
there but for the sake of brevity you
would first do a back-propagation over
time as you can see those recurrent
layers here so you can understand
temporal structure and then here you do
back back propagation only in the note
axis giving you understanding how those
notes relate so now let's see how they
sound like because David's going out put
some text sequence emitting and then we
use a Wolfram language to play it as
many different instruments so this is
the piano
it sounds artificial right it sounds
musical with citizens sound human it's
like a whole new form of artificial
intuition and here's the cello
[Music]
and finally my favorite composition by
this new network
you
now it's worth mentioning that we didn't
that does near a net first created in
there those melodies all by themselves
we didn't have like any supervision as
project in this process it's pure
computation of creativity so me to those
networks actually able to understand
something very fundamental about music
itself but what really is music star
thick that's a great question scan
that's a tall order to answer so before
I started this project I untouched music
for a while and with my experiences with
the piano I thought music was all about
rules and how you improvise within these
constraints that you create for yourself
because I was so used to playing non
euphonic notes I thought that this was
like this was it that a musician
basically had to learn all the rules and
create something out of that over the
course of doing this project oh I
realized something are two fundamental
truths that music has several different
levels of abstraction and that at the
end of that abstraction tree music is
all about connecting with human beings
on an emotional level what do I mean by
that why do you like listening to
bohemian rhapsody by queen is it because
it plays for it place at 143 beats per
minute is it because it's in the b-flat
minor chord is it because of the way
that the violin all sorry the the
guitars seem to have this syncopated
rhythm for if you're interested in the
structure of music and how that
influences you yes but that's not the
only reason there's something more so
could it be because you're interested in
because queen play made the song and
queen are one of the most famous plants
in classical rock that this is a
defining song in classical rock and its
influence many musicians and many other
composers and it relates to our time
period ministry well yes that explains
part of it that explains how we as human
beings relate to culture and how music
can serve as a bridge to that but let's
take it a step further could it also be
because boogie
rhapsody is an emotional rollercoaster
that cycles you through all these
emotions from anger to despair to
hopelessness and by the end of it do you
feel like you you know what it means to
be human and this as artificial
intelligence researchers and as
technologists we see a we hear this
discussion about the contrast between
artificial intelligence and human
intelligence but as human as we believe
that this distinction is quite arbitrary
that what we are all trying to do is
discover the fundamental principles of
intelligence and having discovered this
and coordinate this whether it be
through man or through machine and we we
think it's really quite beautiful for a
human being to be able to compose
something inspire an AI to come up with
something completely unexpected have
that inspired the human being to create
something even more beautiful and just
create beautiful music together and just
explore your creativity in a way that
has never been possible before we think
this is quite fascinating and we were
quiet in awe when we were having
late-night conversations about this
during the hackathon but we also felt
like there was something more to this
that this could be expanded to other
fields so rough definitely so when I was
working in this project I couldn't help
but think cool we're making us really
cool corporations between artificial
intelligence and humans and creativity
but couldn't we apply this concept
generalizes to literally every single
branch of knowledge so I just literally
had a flashback into back when I was six
years old my aunt was absurdly good at
art she could name anything she could
draw it and paint it in perfect detail
and I was always awful at art but I know
that I could sit down of her in a
kitchen and I should be really
passionate about animals have time and
be like auntie can you draw a wolf for
me can make it better you know bigger
edgier and no matter what I told her I
would always have this beautiful picture
of an animal right in front of me even
though I didn't understand anything
about about art whatsoever
because as sarthak said my aunt had all
this knowledge my aunt had all the
knowledge over all those layers
abstraction now what if you can take
this concept of a very intelligent
artificial intelligence expert system
aiding humans into a much more
compelling problem let's take medicine
for example being from Brazil people
suffer a lot from lack of medical
conditions matter of fact it takes
almost ten years to train a doctor in
there a lot of people suffer a lot from
diseases so what I was thinking can we
get material literally from Yale from
Emory from Harvard for mountain I some
of the best medical schools in the world
great artificial intelligence modules in
there they can look at images of you
know they can literally look at medical
imaging and detect cancer lung sandoz or
even be able to look at images of hard
beatings hearts beating done detect
diseases way ahead over time looking at
patients longitudinal records anything
medical you name it and what if it could
get all those modules and give people in
the world access judo's give every
single doctor in those countries access
to a medical facility and the team of
surgeons war for knowledge so they can
affect much more people of it and to
conclude this isn't as a world that we
won only live in a world wouldn't if in
which our juncture of artificial
intelligence hey make it smarter more
talented a more creative and more
efficient society thanks a lot for being
here people if you guys have any
questions for all years are going to be
here for a while thanks a lot
you